and even after sending emails and
requests and even after being told hey
make sure to contact the legal
department it's kind of embarrassing but
we just not getting any answers you're
still not getting any answers even to
this day that's what I got I was a
little bit upset in the phone call Mike
listen man why don't you call me back
I've never seen anything like it
they've taken your money you sent
Facebook a physical check in 2016 to
California they deposit it and we do
this kid on the same take your money
tech capital a world citizen
as promised in the first segment this
man well he needs an introduction I've
been do definitely these this press this
week that was the situation going on
whenever you get into the legal issues
there are things you can't say there's
things you can't say so I said we have a
pretty big show let's skip through it so
I'd like to introduce you of plot Chima
and Richmond PLL CPC our firm partner
there which bodes will for me and my
attorney bill Richmond sorry there I am
well thank you for being on the show sir
I know this isn't typically on your
to-do list probably right it is okay it
was one of our mutual friends Harvard
Law grad and I talked to about something
I've been going on for a while with
Facebook we can get any kind of a
technical issue he just goes like yeah
read rather represent Facebook cuz they
have more money but here's a guy who
probably could help you so I appreciate
the cojones that you have because if
you're just gonna run a numbers game
it's easier to be on the side of the
penis so listen you tell me if I'm out
of line anywhere here because you're my
lawyer he's a lawyer no yeah and he
knows what we can and can't say people
are going forward they've misspoke and
I've corrected them they say a lawsuit
no I've not filed a lawsuit against
Facebook it has nothing to do with this
umbrella term censorship bill you are
the qualified lawyer let the audience
know exactly what it is that we have
done well I think it's easy for folks to
try and say well it's a lawsuit it's in
a court it says you're requesting
something but there's there's a lot of
difference when you actually want to
think about using the word lawsuit of
what what we're asking for or what other
folks are asking for this is a request
for information it is called a petition
if you're a federal court they have
different words for what an initial
lawsuit is and in this one we're looking
for information and that's why it's
titled the way it's timed right we are
looking for information now okay there
are few things we and you'll let me know
what we can't get into what we can
because obvious is a Gizmodo issue goofs
us along but certainly there's a long
paper trail this has been going on for a
while it was I don't know if you call it
a clerical issue a mishandling of
finances and we were at a point where
our technical douche bag issue to take a
clue
lawyer terms to use their term please
face Mark Zuckerberg is watching this
right now and taking notes a year for
incredible liability this is an issue
regarding a clerical tell me to tell
people exactly what this is behind the
scenes that you and I were working on
for a long time
and then we're past the point of no
return we had no more options Gizmodo
gusta DeLong so let them know for those
who can't understand me well for a while
I mean since the since the the thing the
requests that we've been made you tried
to reach out individually before I got
involved and then you we're getting
rebuffed a time and time and time again
and so you decided that you needed to
have someone kind of a little bit more
have to come in and see if we could get
more communications and get open up a
line of communication is about the
problem that we're facing and on this
billing issue that's missus handling of
the payments and even after sending
emails and requests and even after being
told hey make sure to contact the legal
department it's kind of embarrassing but
we're just not getting any answers
you're still not getting any answers
even to this day I was a little bit
upset in the phone call Mike listen man
why don't you call me back they've taken
your money you sent Facebook a physical
check in 2016 to California they deposit
it and we show this kid on the same take
your money tech capital a world sitting
in physical that's like the lady writing
a check in that sardine Isle you know at
the grocery store and then coming back
in her saying we never got the check for
the sardines so just to be clear bill
there's obviously a paper trail you know
that I said we just want to get this
resolved I don't want this going to
creditors they were taking payments from
me before during and after this event
they still are to this day just to run
very low dose ads but for some reason
they wouldn't charge me and they refuse
to acknowledge that they've deposited a
check which we both know they took
that's everything that we're seeing and
that's why we sent those requests that's
why you say your request that's why I
sent my request and that's ultimately
why we're at where our ends another
escalation of we have information and we
have issues and we need to get those
things resolved knock knock knock
someone gonna answer well and obviously
the Gizmodo and you know I told you
right up front I said listen just so you
know
it's well known kind of in conservative
circles people think that there is
selective editing we have had posts
removed with no justification they've
not told us which posts are which cause
I said so I wouldn't be surprised if
this is going on so what we started
talking I said I wouldn't be surprised
if this is going on but I just want to
get this issue resolved because this is
a clear-cut financial issue that we just
want to be over and done with and and
then Gizmodo happened and that raises
some pretty concerning questions as to
why this is happening right that's
exactly the case I mean when we were
looking at this as a billing issue we
thought well they're a big company maybe
it's just a clerical error certainly why
would why would Facebook want to go
after a particular account like this and
then when you listen to all the reasons
that have come out recently this week
not just from Gizmodo but from other
folks who have been jumping on that
story and revealing even more facts it
does start to lend you to think this is
the answer to the why the billing issues
were happening in addition to the other
issues in terms of your accounts right
because in addition to issue in addition
to the evidence that people see in front
of the scenes and tell me if I'm out of
line here you have seen a ton of emails
screenshots posts inconsistencies that
we looked at and we're going okay well
we want to go down that road but you've
been aware of this for a while right
certainly it's it's public is ultimately
it's public facing if someone were to be
watching your page all the time they may
even have been able to see this as well
posts that go up both us they go down
posts that come back and behind all of
this again is your ongoing requests and
then ultimately our ongoing requests for
transparency what's happening can't you
tell us right exactly let me ask you
this to boil it down so I sent them back
and forth emails with accounts payable I
made several accounts available to them
accounts that they still use for again
these low great ads we are independent
we don't have anyone else running ads
for us it comes entirely from not gay
Jerrod and myself these are still
running today the same accounts that I
made available to them for this very
specific payment I reached out I tried
to get on the phone I finally had you
reach out you went through all of your
avenues would was there any other option
aside from filing for this petition for
information at this point because they
still haven't resolved it the only other
option
just let me get away with it I mean it
would have been saying well you can just
keep my money and keep doing this but
you know ultimately that's why this is
exactly the way that it is it's not a
lawsuit for damages and people keep
trying to characterize it that way it
really is a request for information and
it's an escalation of the requests that
have gone to this day unanswered I will
say this had never I haven't spent a lot
of time with them in person bill Richman
when you hear on the phone this is not
what I pictured I'll tell you I'll tell
you if I can't a real quick story yes
funny when I show up in an interview
with the name bill Richmond and then I
walk in and people are like I don't
think I ordered any lo mein and I'm like
you're far less jewy than I imagined
your sister's Jewish yeah she converted
made it happen for love so she so so
going back to this this is where we are
and and of course people are going
around there being yours but I just feel
like news hosts of water are
irresponsible when they say lawsuit or
they interchangeably for example use
battery and assault which happened with
the Donald Trump Corey Lewandowski thing
and it wasn't even necessarily someone
who filed the report
but someone misreported it right we see
that happening all the time yes
so we've clarified exactly what this is
and elected before the break the only
other option at this point that we had
on the financial side was sit down take
it they took the money never let them
respond and it would go to collections
like a like a Jim processing fee we've
all had that right yeah that's that's
ultimately where they could have taken
it because according to their records as
they continue to say over and over again
no payments have been made on this
account again despite the check despite
the fact that they're taking money
through another account on the same
payment methods you've never had this
have you ever had this before I mean
know what imagine you deal with these
kind of like basic small courts issues
all the time but have you ever had it
get to this point with any other company
before no I know a lot of companies
they'll maybe initially they'll brush it
off were for example a lower-level
person will say you know they'll just
ignore it because they don't really
understand the gravity of the situation
but even here we've even our legal
requests have come back with well you
need to talk to legal and our responses
we've been trying to contact legal and
they're ignoring it so it's we know
that they're getting the requests and
other companies would oftentimes get on
the phone give you a call send you a
letter even just a letter that says we
don't think there's a problem here right
but here there's just no response well
okay that begs a question for me
despite ignorance or collusion whatever
the reason is is that legal to just not
respond to legal requests well to a
request from from a lawyer sending a
letter we sent that as a non legal
maneuver in this particular example
where we have the petition to to not
answer it's not illegal in the sense of
a crime but there once served with the
petition they have an obligation to
respond if they want to do anything in
in the petition it's okay well and again
I want to make sure the people
understand we're not suing because I
don't like conservatives they can do
whatever they want right the issue with
Facebook and we know this we've seen
this with Twitter is the social media
platform that's most valuable is the one
that's most effective user friendly and
namely the one that they trust they're
only as valuable as the trust of their
users now if they tell their and right
now currently as of this show they are
swearing up and down that they do not
curate they do not selectively edit or
censor for lack of a better word any
Content they're swearing up and down
right now people can go read an article
of Mark Zuckerberg own alive Mike
selling Merkel you're gonna get rid of
these anti-immigration stories so
they're swearing up and down they
haven't done it which I think bill you
correct I think that's making the
situation worse for them because I have
said they have the right and defended
their right but if they're saying that
and there is any proof that the public
knows if that happens to be true or
maybe something that perhaps we have
experienced if there is any proof that
what they're saying is untrue that's a
real problem if it does a big problem it
creates a big problem with we're selling
a product that does a certain thing and
is handled in a certain way and that's
the ad services and the users that are
ultimately part of it and in reality is
a completely different situation a lot
of the stories these days are in the
last few days have said time and time
and time again we use an algorithm it's
completely objective based on the
criteria that we put in don't worry
about it and now apparently there's a
lot of questions about that right well
and that's for the that's for the users
and then of course
to the paying advertisers on which
Facebook make billions I would assume
hundreds of - so much money
were they court advertisers right they
tell people you can go right out of
facebook ads we're the best place and
they give you the pitch why and that's
the one time where you can actually get
in contact with somebody when they want
you to start advertising because we are
the biggest social media platform it is
an open and free exchange of information
once you acquire these people they're
your fans that was another thing people
got upset about you have you started
having to pay to reach your own fans and
that's something that's that's
well-documented it's not a political
issue so if they're saying that and
they're courting people and then
potentially harming the brand that
they're courting to pay them it would
seem to me regardless of whether it's
political or they just don't like your
face that's an issue it does forget an
issue and it's not something that just
strikes one side or the other I mean you
know in this particular case it could go
either way so it's less about it's less
about which side is being held down or
suppressed or targeted as the article
went to list but what is being sold to
these business partners and people who
are giving hundreds of thousands of
dollars to make this happen I mean other
small businesses are out there counting
on Facebook to allow their posts to go
through right and based on a certain
understanding of how it works well I'll
tell you and Jerry tonight Nucky Jarrett
is my producer he knows this we've and
many conservatives out there have just
said like yeah you can invest this in
Facebook and it'll work short term but
part of your business model just has to
be it could all go away because Facebook
chooses to and they change
oh yeah their whole way of doing it
that's just people take we've had that
use for the algorithms just since last
year we've had a couple rice like
Facebook change up interface but you got
to readjust everything and you just
never know when that algorithm doesn't
include your business right we've always
come out on top because we've always
focused on creating good original
content and a user experience so it's
benefited us I mean I'm the first to say
Facebook has been immensely beneficial
to independent voices like myself for
people out there this happens a lot
Facebook will remove posts and we've had
this happen so this is something I mean
I don't wanna get to do it said A
through Z and you know there's more
information that you go through in a
lifetime but a Facebook just removes a
post and they say it's a violation of
policy well what happens is right if
we're uploading let's say five six posts
a day we can't know which post they
refuse to say which post
he's okie which policy say we're not
going to tell you which policy in
business doesn't there have to be some
semblance of good faith where you can go
hey man we're sorry if we violated a
policy we want to work with Facebook
which is what we said we're really happy
to work with you but could you tell us
which post was in violation of which
policy we're not gonna tell you which
poster which policy doesn't that pose a
problem it does pose a problem when you
look at the Terms of Service or the
other agreements that business users
have and that they have when they're
submitting this money for ads there may
be some language that deals with that
but ultimately a lot of states have laws
that say you have to have a product be
what you have represented it to be and
in these particular cases again we're
raising a lot of questions based on the
article from Gizmodo and those that have
come out since then about whether or not
the product that is Facebook and what's
being all the money that's going to them
for I is what they've represented it to
be right and in my case this is
something to that I've talked about
we've talked about on the show I've
caught a couple because every now I
don't know how many posts have been
removed like you said someone publicly
could have caught this but I caught
three and said hey this was removed and
they were all put back they said oh
sorry that was an error but if I
wouldn't have caught it it would have
been removed for some arbitrary reason
maybe someone was offended and it
potentially depending can count as a
knock against your account and then your
account is gone into which you invested
finances exactly right
so and that is something that we've
experienced now again I want to be clear
our motion is or petition like you said
I guess some depending on that where you
are is simply to reveal information
right no financial damages we're not
looking for a specific amount we still
happen to this day we still don't have
the problem remedied and we're going why
we need the information to answer why so
if there's nothing going on it would
seem like Facebook should just say well
okay well here's why that's the
expectation at this point is that you
know perhaps you give them a bit of the
doubt that this got stuck in someone's
inbox or some lower-level person in
their in-house department just didn't
catch it and that's why we've had to
escalate it so ultimately no this isn't
a request for money this isn't a request
saying look what we've got you know all
of these causes of action and we want to
go after you and get something out of
you besides information and that's
really what the question the answers
that we want from this petition right
and we need this specifically again
because
of the monetary issue they've taken
money and that can that is something
very tangible on the flip side it'd be
nice if Facebook did that with very
loyal
advertisers in good standing who've been
in professional relationships with them
where they would just say eh yeah this
post violated this policy or hey you
know what we just decided that we don't
we don't like you instead they just
don't contact they take the money they
take money they take money they don't
contact and then sometimes people get
the boot
what about consistency of policy if
let's say for example maybe Facebook
took specific ad money to promote a post
so let's say they took money to promote
it because you know they did a lot boost
a post and then that exact same post
they then later said what's a violation
of policy if hypothetically they took
money on that specific post is that a
problem or again does a business have
the right to just change their their
guidelines at any point or there's some
expectancy of consistency as an investor
well there's there's agreements that are
agreed to between the folks who are
sending the money for the ads the
business users and Facebook and so to
the extent that Facebook is deciding to
change those policies it does have a
right to be able to change those
policies with a certain amount or notice
and that's type of thing and even having
language built-in that says we have the
right to change our mind about how it's
going to be done but again it gets back
to the issue of if you've advertised
publicly setting aside the contracts and
you've told other people time and time
again this is how we run our news feed
this is how we take money this is how we
apply that money and then now it's being
done differently that creates an issue
aside from the contract well what what
they say they don't curate anything
right that's what they claim again they
have the right to what does a judge do
this is again hypothetically until you
don't to get into its well-known mark
Mark Zuckerberg right we wrote about it
said into a live mic was caught - Angela
Merkel saying yeah we're gonna we're
gonna have to do something with these
Antti was an anti-immigration or anti
German government I think it wasn't it
was in a Muslim immigration with the
German government we're I think anti
anti Merkel yeah that's documented
so is there I would just have to imagine
doesn't someone have to look and say
okay they're claiming this unless we
have access to all documents there is an
inconsistency with what Mark Zuckerberg
himself has said that's documented that
all of us is public right it's not just
it's not just mark but what other folks
are saying in
Facebook hierarchy about it and in other
context where they were not under fire
they have made statements about how
their algorithms work and how they how
they treat the business users the ads
the posts and how those things show on
the outside and the newsfeed and those
will be held against them if it turns
out that there's some kind of
inconsistency there there you go and
what we're looking to accomplish right
now is get information and resolve the
problem as painlessly as possible
correct exactly exactly look at him he's
a nice man of Platte Chima and Richmond
PLLC Bryan Richmond he's not delivering
your low main get it right Bryan thank
you and please come back and set us
straight anytime we say something
incorrect thanks David appreciate it
Thank You Bryan we'll keep you posted as
this story unfolds guys who knows where
it'll go a lot or with Crowder's stay
tuned this clip it's taken from the
full-length podcast every week you can
click that box down below to watch the
full free video casts or subscribe on
iTunes to watch them to go click my face
to go to ladder with writer comm where
we write plenty of articles columns and
upset those who are easily triggered or
click below me there's some other video
down there I don't know what it is yet
not gay Jarrod is going to toss it's
probably going to be something ambiguous
but uncomfortable